It is time for hatred, mail, hatred, mail
is when a professional voiceover artist does
interpretive readings of the hate mail that
I get.
Quick reminder about Patriot mail.
Hey, let's face it.
The only logical response guns
is more Firkin guys.
Hey Trey at Mayo, written by Patriots.
Who?
Hey David Pacman because America and because
freedom.
All right.
This one combines race, realism, antisemitism,
and just regular old insults against me.
Take a look.
You a patronizing propagandizing douchebag.
Please stop making your awful videos.
That is the only constructive criticism I
can give you.
Find a new job.
Hell, find a job.
It's clear you are a low IQ individual.
More sad than anything.
Jews are often high IQ, but it sounds like
it missed you
very naturally.
I have to say that there's a certain cleverness
to it.
Very naturally working in race and IQ stuff
into the hatred, male, while also insulting
me.
Uh, fight hatred IOTs prism by using the coupon
code.
Hatred 40.
When you sign up for a membership@joinpacman.com
the normal membership rates I find to be extraordinarily
reasonable and a very good value.
$6 a month or 60 for the year.
If you want subscribe using the coupon code
hatred at 40 it'll drop the price, 40% hatred.
It's cry when you do it and you still get
100% of the member benefits.
It's great stuff.